I have always said from the outset that
on any large piece of legislation like
this they're going to be things that
need to be improved you need to be
tweaked I said that I think the day I
signed the bill even though I think
Obamacare is a truly epic mistake here
are three obvious ways to make the
president's signature legislative
achievement better cheaper and more
cost-effective they're going to be
things that need to be improved you need
to be tweaked as it stands only people
under 30 and a few other folks can buy
cheap catastrophic plans that cover a
few regular procedures but protect you
against very costly medical emergencies
catastrophic plans are much cheaper than
the cheapest comprehensive bronze plans
at healthcare.gov one of the selling
points of Obamacare was that it would
let people choose plans that fit their
needs if a catastrophic plan is what you
want why not be allowed to buy one
they're going to be things that need to
be improved you need to be tweaked
health insurance companies in cahoots
with State Insurance Commission have
carved up their territories like
old-school mob families a true national
market that would force insurers to
compete for customers on the basis of
price and service would expand consumer
options and eventually lead to new ways
of doing business that works in auto and
home insurance and it would work with
health insurance too they're going to be
things that need to be improved you need
to be tweaked Obamacare increases the
demand for medical care but does
virtually nothing to grow its supply
that's a recipe for shortages and long
wait times the quickest way to grow the
supply of health care is to ditch all
sorts of barriers ranging from super
slow FDA approval processes for new
drugs and devices to protectionists
professional licensing too tightly
restricted medical school admissions
almost 3 dozen states even give existing
hospitals in indirect say and whether
new competing hospitals can be built
scrapping all of these and more would
make healthcare easier and cheaper to
get I think that Obamacare is not just a
dumb law but a deeply offensive one in a
perfect world it would be repealed and
we'd actually move towards a true free
market in health care but in the world
we actually live in Obamacare isn't
going away anytime soon the least we can
do in the
time is make it less horrible for reason
TV I'm Nicholas me